and what's interesting about this
problem is that it was actually solved
by what might be called an amateur
mathematician someone that wasn't
officially a mathematician
so i first encountered
163 when studying a little bit of basic
number theory and it came up in the most
mysterious way that fascinated me
because it's the last number in a short
list of numbers even though it seems
very innocuous it has some very
mysterious properties so you may have
heard about factoring numbers you may
not remember exactly what that means so
let's just review that if you start out
with a whole number say 12 you can write
it as a product of numbers in many
different ways so you could think of 12
as being 6 times 2
or you could think of it as being
4 times 3 but
if you want to write it as a product of
prime numbers there's
only one way to do it
up to the ordering
in which you write the numbers
so 2 and 3 are both prime numbers so
every whole number can be written in
exactly one way as a product of prime
numbers up to the order in which the
numbers are written any number any
number all right i'm going to give you
one you ready i know okay yeah um 20.
that is going to be
2 times 2 times
5.
and each one of those is a prime number
a mathematician named gauss was
trying to identify all of the
perfect pythagorean triples so what are
these these are the whole numbers
a b and c
that satisfy this equation and what this
means geometrically the reason these
would be called pythagorean triples
is that
these numbers
are the side lengths for a right
triangle
the most common example
of a perfect
pythagorean triple would be three four
and five
and so the natural question is
well we can find specific examples how
do we find an exhaustive list of all the
examples of pythagorean triples
and what gauss noticed is that well if
we take the idea of factorization of
ordinary whole numbers to a new number
system
that we can make some progress
and so the way that he created this new
number system was to take all of the
whole numbers and add i
it's sometimes
denoted this way
so he takes all of the whole numbers
that's what this z corresponds to
and he adds i so this consists of all of
the
numbers
that can be written this way where the a
and the b are whole numbers
and i
is
the square root of minus 1.
well what he noticed is that
he could factorize this expression
if he just had i
in a way that can't be done in the
ordinary number system
so if we take a squared plus b squared
you might remember from school that this
can't be factorized in any nice way
using ordinary numbers if it were
instead of difference of squares there
would be a nice way to do it but
if we allow ourselves to use
i
we can actually write this
and what's more the special property
that each number can be factorized into
primes in exactly one way carries over
to this new number system now you have
to expand your notion of what a prime is
because you've got now new numbers
so they may or may not be primes and it
could be that what used to be primes
are no longer primes in the new system
but
what he also discovered was that
if we
adjoin other numbers instead
we might not get the same result so for
example in this number system this is
just
all the normal numbers except that we
now allow ourselves
this one new number
so this one
still is a number system but it has the
unfortunate property that it doesn't
have unique factorization
so just to give you an example
in this number system
we have the number six
which could be written as a product two
times three
but
at the same time it can be written as
this product
this is a problem because
here we have one way to decompose it
into a product of primes and here we
have another way that's completely
different using completely different
primes it's not just a matter of
rearranging the ordering
so so it worked for the square root of
minus one it didn't work for the square
root of minus five where are we going
here so what he observed was that it
doesn't work for all numbers but he did
identify quite a few for which it did
work
and specifically
he identified a list of numbers we still
do have the unique factorization
provided we choose one of the following
numbers d
well one
these are the numbers for which
we get unique factorization
and then
there's a big jump
to
this number
so that one works and this one works as
you can tell it's quite a bit
uh removed from the previous one
and what gauss conjectured was that this
was the last one
that for some reason
with this number the list stops and no
matter what other number after this you
add you no longer have unique
factorization
he conjectured that this was really the
way it was that it was true but he could
never actually prove it i can see why
you thought that number intrigued you
now
the problem is to try to actually show
that this is the last number for which
this happens that this list is
exhaustive that there are no other
numbers of this sort that one can add in
order to get unique factorization
in the new number system tough nut to
crack then it was a very tough nut to
crack and what's interesting about this
problem is that it was actually solved
by what might be called an amateur
mathematician someone that wasn't
officially a mathematician
so a german by the name
of higner
actually found a proof in the
50s
and he did actually publish his result
but it wasn't accepted by the
mathematical community for several years
and in the 60s some well-established
mathematicians a british mathematician
by the name of baker and an american by
the name of stark
found other proofs which were generally
accepted and then after a couple of
years
one of those mathematicians stark went
back to what higner had done analyzed it
in more detail and realized hold on a
second he did actually have a proof it
was actually okay
with just some minor issues
so and what did hagnify what was gauss
right
he was right these this is the end of
the list and mysteriously these are the
only ones
and there are some other
interesting and mysterious um
consequences of this that you wouldn't
guess just from the way these are
presented
so one of these is
the fact that there are certain numbers
that ramune john had identified as being
very close to whole numbers
so among these
are
this number
and who knows how he managed to
determine this but ramune jean did
observe that these were close to to
whole numbers surprisingly close
and as a sort of joke um in the 70s the
recreational mathematician martin
gardner
wrote in one of his columns that
ramunejan's conjecture
had finally been proven namely that
this
was a whole number
so here we've got the number e
here we've got the number pi
and this is taking e
to this power
so e is anything but a whole number it's
as far from a whole number as you could
expect to be likewise for pi
the square root of 163
is also not a whole number so it would
be extremely surprising if you took this
combination and somehow wound up with
the whole number and you don't but he
was able to fool people because it's so
close to a whole number that with the
techniques that most people would have
had available that in those days they
wouldn't have been able to to tell the
difference
it's extremely close to a massive whole
pi
is very close to a whole number
in any way related to all this stuff
we've already been talking yes in fact
the fact that you get all of these
from those
is directly related to that fact not in
an obvious way it's it's quite involved
to see exactly how that works but it is
in fact related to that
and i'm not even sure how it is that
ramona jean was able to identify these
i'm not sure that he
knew about these properties but he did
identify those as being very close to to
whole numbers very strange
it's not something that i think ordinary
people would ever have expected and
who knows why it was that gauss
conjectured that this would be true
because
one might also expect that since you
have this big gap between 67 and 163
that the next one might just be very far
along and before people had computers
how would they have known how could they
possibly check so i wouldn't have
guessed that i don't know who would
other than someone
like gauss but it's a very mysterious uh
fact but
one that has now been established
and that's why you think 163 is a pretty
cool number it is a very cool number is
it like your pin number or the
combination on your briefcase no no but
it is uh it is certainly one of my
favorite numbers
you